الجيش المعنوي للاخوان المسلمين هذا
المهمه بس اضيف هذه واختهم فيها كلام اذا
الجيش المعنوي في الاخوان المسلمين تمثل
عندنا هنا في المملكه
اه
انا من الجيل اللي شاهدنا لعبه تغيير
المناهج
المناهج التي نعرفها بدات تتغير ونعرف
الاشخاص باسمائهم الذي كان لهم دور في
تغيير المناهج لم يكونوا من الاخوان
المسلمين
ولم يعطوا بيعه للمرشد العام كانوا من
الذين يرون ان الاخوان هذول حقا اخوانهم
اخوانهم المسلمين
اهل كلمه لقالها الملك عبد العزيز حسن
البنا لما في الحج وقال اني اريد افتح فرع
عندك وقال لها الملك عبد العزيز كلنا
اخواننا كلنا مسلمون يعني هذا المعنى
الحقيقي عند البنا المعنى السياسي
كانوا يظنون هؤلاء بالمعنى الحقيقي اللي
هو لكلمه
او اخ مسلم قضيه اسلاميه
واشتغلوا لمصلحه تغيير المناهج وهم ليسوا
اخوان المسلمين لكن تبين بعدين ان المشروع
اخواني بعد ما غير كل شيء
مشروع للحزب انه يعيد تكوين البيئه في
المملكه وفي الخليج العامه
التكوين اللي بالكويت لانه هو اللي براز
بشكل واضح وقوي وصادم وصارم لانه جاك
اخوان مسلمون وواضحون جدا في السعوديه لا
في حاله تبعثر لانهم جيش معنوي كان بصفه
هي لما تكشف لهم من الامراض غير ما يظنون